speaking of history black soldiers have
played a major role in our united states
armed forces since the 1700s in the
revolutionary war
all the way to present day now while
black service members are visible
they're still climbing the ranks
into lead roles
[Music]
during the pandemic our united states
air force thunderbirds flew across our
skies to honor
frontline workers energy is always high
folks are excited kids are screaming and
yelling and jumping up and down with
excitement
as america's ambassadors in blue they've
got a secret weapon that keeps them
running smoothly
captain rimo shay nelson this is
something that i've always wanted to be
a part of
i was just kind of like blown away and
speechless but also like very excited
for the opportunity
to be a part of this team nelson a
howard university graduate
has lived across the world korea germany
turkey and now nellis air force base
coming from modest beginnings it was her
stepfather's stories of his time in the
navy
that left an impression i am so thankful
because he really taught me the
importance of serving others
nelson is the thunderbird's first black
female officer
when i found out i was extremely humbled
she's the team's public affairs officer
her role is selective nelson is the 12th
person to have the position since the
team started in 1953.
she leads an incredible team and as a
leader of that team they're the first
people to interface with the public
black soldiers have played a major role
in armed forces
from the buffalo soldiers tuskegee
airmen to the air force chief of staff
general charles brown for young black
girls to be able to see themselves in me
for them to get an opportunity to see
what's possible is
an absolute honor when we can inspire
folks to do that because they can relate
to us
that's very effective we can only do
that when we display diversity
and her vision for the future i hope
that we continue
to grow as a force and to be a
reflection of the people that we
actually serve